whoa geez 45 is my favorite number five
now your favorite number is it I love
that you like everything nothing I'm
giving something
[Music]
what
it'll probably
it'll be
ah
what if I didn't do this was the last
Monday morning in her life
he's going to talk to school this
morning 8th graders a lot of fun now on
the way to record and film The Breakfast
Club which the real amazing moment 2016
brought some awareness to my work to a
lot of different people which I enjoyed
has become very fond of the characters
over there and some going to come back
and answer some questions with a bow to
that and just gave a lot of different
meanings should be an interesting day
I'm feeling good gonna get up you know I
actually love to get like six hours of
sleep sometimes even like a speaking of
seven obviously have a lot of fours and
fives is going to consistent four and
five weeks so last few days feel a
little like rundown in the morning but
very quickly it changes
who's the energy can go from zero to 100
real quick hey hey good morning the
rocking the house things good hope
everybody super well thank you so much
and doll how's everybody doin 30 day
challenge twenty thousand dollars twenty
thousand 170 yeah baby [ __ ] hell that
baby [ __ ] a [ __ ] sells good stuff does
like that's one of my favorite things
like people own all these baby clothes
and all these baby items they got no
babies no more some of you babies just
flew in the attic gonna do a garage sale
so for a dollar 90 things that kind of
sold for food 1,100 bucks boom Gary B
shop calm please peach that's ready
t-shirt Turner you think maybe pump
additional devices alright how about for
I think you should buy for I'll buy for
then give three right or even what a vie
for anyway
d-roc I am very proud of you I think my
6i me I'm a Salesman man don't laugh
don't laugh you know if you like this if
you like this right in the clinic how
you do it
keep going totally sing no keep going
until they say no don't say no for the
other guy
keep going till they say no not you you
want me
sales keep shelling until they say no if
you like so I like some wine
did you like a case yeah great okay here
you maybe need another kids okay maybe
she might keep them putting away for
York in one day okay
mini top okay no three cases which is
better one
always communicate it's the culture it's
the people it's never ever ever ever
ever anything other than that it's about
people when we go from one to five
locations it's about people
that's the [ __ ] game so get a
computer that's 100% a game that barkas
to you the substrate
20,000 in profit so that you don't pay
bills with the sales we pay with a
profit profit profit profit profit
profit topic I'll keep the content
coming love you guys let me stand
benroubi but please please please Oh
Ricky is yourself please please please
keep it coming keep building your [ __ ]
sell [ __ ] you [ __ ] do it do it do it and
and I wish you guys huge love all right
I got to go in some breakfast club look
forward to it
you rock the filming so we'll catch it
I'll see you guys later
Russian husk of your life
that's how you don't hear thunder your
life how are you bro man this man will
like this my man how you run a business
you need a scion a agency of social
media agency so we help you know Under
Armour Toyota do all the Facebook
Instagram snapchat sharing like that man
I think that's you know that's work
that's what the thing man
commence the lucky thank you folks
that's me all right stay well moral that
story is you could be picking up five
thousand people a day on Instagram but
if you don't take the time and say hello
and put just one person on that's only
gonna last for so long what am I meant
so I don't I don't
good to see you Hemet never that's my
man come in what's up everybody it's
gary vee wake up every morning with
breakfast club only honorable
you got it thanks let's go pleasure me
so weak that ass up just that's it you
wake that ass up the best part
come on great thank you guys yeah come
on you like treating you really gonna do
well can you sing you know what well hey
just feeling really well thing what's up
my brother got my man crazy isn't I saw
you at CSU rot you were sit with some
guys I was with Dan Gilbert sitting
right behind you always calling your
name then I got pulled that I looked and
I see you then I heard on other cloud
I'm gonna go so it's good to see it as a
great meeting so they had a bit I never
got anything
I wish there I went there with that Tom
Hanks and Howard Stringer women's head
of yeah absord
and you know this is like 10 years is
for sure washing it was when it was
really a Electronic Show now it's just a
business with human success okay thank
you I grab you for a second we're just
going to do a quick promo video
so you're gonna be on the trip I'm up
um me with a long run of the kicks man
good to see you
look it's good as your living good good
got Bobby all good I'm going to get I
think I'm very far and very close so
unexplained
I love patients I got a lot of things in
place on third base that I haven't
cashed in on a lot of things I can do
if tomorrow it has to happen call in a
little bit we'll call in all those
favors cash in all those chips Celal but
you know my company just got a huge
transaction it's that valued the company
in a four hundred million dollar
valuation that puts my network at 200
million of what I own of that I've got
all this paper money on Facebook I can
cash it all in it's on the stock market
I've got private money and over and
other things and I can convert to
somebody else I've got pieces but what
he's not selling and the truth is I
don't have the 2.7 billion I'm nowhere
close to that now and I don't want to go
round up a lot of people to be a partner
I want a run [ __ ] I need to win a Super
Bowl so the good news is he's still
young he's you know I wish him help
every single day I need about another I
would love to have another 15 to 20
years to make the play but the truth is
I mean the journey to try to buy them
that's the game after game you know that
last night outside last night
47 and and Boyd we go to the studio
right you know what I love no I love
hip-hop the most people people that are
really in it they work like I'm in
corporate America I'm in Silicon Valley
actually that's why I fell in love with
Silicon Valley those nerds they works
like my hip-hop friends did I'm like
wait a minute our coding at 2:00 in the
morning right like going to studio last
night in Midtown at 12:00 and watching
everybody work they beast work he's
working they're working very good every
day I was a bird last night over here
oh you don't show with you right yeah
like like and you know why it it more of
a --ts me because in corporate america
when i go sit with CMOS and ceos of 20
fortune 500 companies they don't work
like this I'm done at six
I've got garyvee always a pleasure man
nothing man yes sir let me feel better
pleasure pleasure through words I'm
answering thank you my man
how about me write about you to click
the link email right now when an
academic basket down and then edit mom's
in case you know I'm really looking at
all of them we're talking about
thousands of people whose life is better
than staff like like like crazy [ __ ]
that's a good way to set up the
voicemail we can have people calling me
like clintus oh that's a cool i love
them i do like the boy screams yeah
whatever well talk to you hey thank you
talk to you sooner
bye guys I'm happiest about almost so
luxury I guess yeah
listen Tom holds on back when now we
talk about exact happy yep now I get to
talk about it's a back from South Beach
highly natural we celebrate but I wanna
see more my mom we meet I just talk
about the sunshine that the watch the
rain stop all because of sunshine that's
what that part
[Music]
and let that be a lesson for the next 50
years that we jam together but if you
ever want context doesn't seem like it
was bothering you but anytime Ling's my
you things for some you hear me say it
I'm going with a new tactic in these
first time meetings anytime something
happens that you don't understand or
like and you want to know I'm super cozy
to tell you I got a big dream of the
town hall meeting but I realized that
that's only gonna bring me so much so
now my new move is to let them know from
the first moment they sit with me like
call my bluff em again but whatever you
deem is important and not important yeah
I'm sure that's not the crazy like I'm
sure that's not the craziest thing
that's ever happened but but but
everybody's different
like it's insane what people think of
real pleasure okay give me up I can be
help already
hey woman thank you man just going on
Instagram fly for a second but I'll shut
down how are you okay well then you
listen they're going to [ __ ] their pants
if you come in so let me get this
straight your fruit real life right now
if you like hi I'm giving myself a tour
okay let me get this so there's not your
last building there and they're not
going to be yeah you might want to get
some be acquainted with those you're a
rope I can go out there myself we'll do
it right now
well that's how you make your content
okay why don't you drone up here like go
up here and just clean it I mean there
it is the next music content figure it
out series first and foremost Congrats
bummer
yeah so happy you such idea I'd never
said this the day after I stopped doing
why I reconnected five and a half years
I have five days a week I mean in five
years I did a thousand eighty nine
episodes and I didn't do weekends so
like when you start compounding that
math it was like the world came off my
shoulders and it was my finger thing but
when it was over and I knew it was over
I did something weird I actually did
something a lot of people don't know I
didn't wanna be TVs episode a thousand
and then I started something called
daily grape which is a shorter mobile
version because because I knew I was
done at a thousand but I wasn't ready to
let go this weird thing some like most
I'm going to do it
learn something new and I think these
mobile devices are going to take over so
I did that but I only did 489 episodes
it never had a chance that I ended it
yeah no it was killing and I was making
money because I actually for first time
actually the selling wine reviews like
Wine Spectator it would have been a huge
business I was just done doing daily
content that way pressing vertical for
me delivery yes it's not a by accident
that good things happen to us it's this
so absolutely it's just a traditional
media has existed for so long so sort of
changed so big it's not their fault it's
not so bad it can't pivot they can which
is why this move by them getting your
Bobby so like Instagram is so important
either daily done versus stories hundred
fifty maybe active users and story so a
project is what a few more glowing they
have any attention they funneled people
in that way what you do again the people
that win you do not disrespect that
attention you don't owe you nothing then
disrespect that attention so once you
figure out once you figure out exactly
you'll deploy it against that attention
with value to that attention and there
will be a hit from the gate that's
exactly what can happen and that's why
it that's why they stole it in a world
where everybody goes like people don't
understand magic you understand finding
blowing up or defeated ten years making
me take a picture but to have to take so
the stuff that any job wouldn't have
believed it to be like your gear the
Empire State Building as a window this
is a view of the entire State Building
for my bed yeah Miriam I dance is my
dance exam is because I need to eat as a
and sweet New York severe we got to be
getting around your chair but up solovey
say crumbs I hear it haha you gotta come
down anytime you guys forgot to do your
job well laughs I can love it Nana
someone watch the video post six about
exactly just says cool it's about this
idea of what the lion watch it yeah yeah
yeah I can do it I would never go and
watch my first Casey videos but never
hold you to it it's like eight minutes
Sirach you up here on time here I come
you ever watch the PC video was the one
day is about sort of this fungus bit see
how I talked about last week which is
like whoa these five five is my favorite
number five Tigers favorite number is it
I love that you like every semester I'm
actually give you something
cocktails somebody's [ __ ] internet
dinner date on you you know because it's
happened to you guys but one of the kind
of objections definitely get all the
time is you know we have people who do
this or our kids do the stories we've
got people internally to do this and
it's you know I tell them that there's a
big difference between the way I play
basketball and the way LeBron James
plays back there's no accident that
Ella's the best you've got
right you just tell them right to their
[ __ ] face that we're better at it
yeah and if they say well we don't value
the difference between our B player and
your a player then you say Mazel Tov and
you go into the next building yeah don't
dwell on that conversation tell them
right in the face what you believe and
move on cool I mean it's that basic yeah
what are you gonna try to convince the
unsellable right I don't give a [ __ ]
what your excuses it's the excuse and
I'm leaving you need to really nail that
one in your brain it will be the best
thing that happens to your business
sitting in your bed crying about the
girls that didn't want to go out with
you for a year is not going to let you
find the next girl yeah next degree so
when you're not tripping or you have a
wavering I yes you're unfaithful that
skirt looks cute I get it I've never you
know it's when it comes to
entrepreneurship I'm playing the field
hard I'm super in love with Vayner but
I'm like clue that and that happens to
me every day I'm a scum bucket when it
comes to entrepreneurship and I would
tell you that you can go and have a
little more fun once you've got a little
bit of an established situation so I
would say that be very careful of not
doing it too early and realize you know
there's something I said the other day
like eat [ __ ] for 24 months and then
caviar the rest of your life it's not
that exact but that's how I think about
here build something that gives you the
thought you know build something and
then when it's got enough strength go do
it the reason there was a big gap in me
putting out content was I needed two
thousand eleven twelve and thirteen to
build Vayner it allowed me them to get
back into content do the pure Wow deal
you know yeah very kind
I really don't actually thank you work
out for you maybe it's not gratitude
brother
drive with that do not let any like when
I give you that first answer to that
question now that should be a foregone
conclusion yeah comparatively do never
you know is what happens with
life-threatening events you forget it's
like it's like getting it's like when
the cop car goes and then when it drives
back by you you get I mean you start
driving fast again people don't realize
if you do I understand is that god I've
never had it
people forget do not forget music but
but but you know what
don't say it live it right using that
client somebody say no nothing okay so
but I just want to make sure let me
sleep on it
get me some context hi hi Kelly Kelly
how are you hi Tina
Dana how are you just so weird building
my dad's liquor store it should have
been two hundred million dollar business
I wasn't smart enough to go all in on
Google AdWords I kind of went all in on
that AdWords it's insane to me like I
don't even want to actually put my brain
on the table for you guys to see on how
I think about pure Wow and Instagram
because it would make you nervous
because you would then be concerned that
I'm so disrespectful to everything else
so with that opening statement that's
how I feel about things that's why I
think I win so to me that could go away
tomorrow
the reason I've been successful with
clients with my investments the things
that are not 100% my call we're super
successful because we look at each other
and we just do it everything else is
hard veiners hard this is easy we just
do it I just do it and when they have
idea like do it just do it and we do it
and it's just doing it
Bader's hard we have to do it like so I
do it but I have to do a couple of
things before him and this will be one
even step more of than that and that's
okay but this is what I'm about you know
and it's going to work in a real way
love you guys right yeah you see where
the opportunities are that
what's the right mood help first figure
out cool excited I see you like every
day on TV or on YouTube I have a crazy
proposition for you okay I don't I
yeah so just oh my god let it makes my
heart swell to see this it's so great
here's my feeling as a father and a man
in the world is someone who strikes is
focused a lot of my life on attacking
many people like that as far as wide as
I could in a positive way and suddenly
they got real small I cared about just
being in the room with them I think a
real Collazo you trying to have a big
ass off for a small problem where do you
find it and you know what the best part
is yeah the answer is always both yeah
and the clouds and dirt baby and that's
allowed something like well for a moment
I felt like I had anything actually made
it through it will be very eyes well
they're gonna grow up in this world
well that's an elephant yeah parents and
marketers and business people they
[ __ ] themselves they [ __ ]
themselves in not realizing you can be a
hundred percent on something even for a
year everybody thinks in the micro like
if I want to be super selfish for two
years it's two of the hundred years I'm
gonna live right right like people don't
quantify that I'll go in the dirt for
like for bigger media I was in the
clouds for the last six months I'm
getting in the dirt you know people
people join you themselves too much it's
okay to go on a business trip for three
weeks it's three weeks yeah yeah it's
okay that you know especially I mean
look this is so much of the advice I
gave you on the board right like well
let me get a vision Yamaha and I'm on
like it
so
yeah listen to my holds on track but now
we talk about things ahead and happier
but now I get to talk about the best
South Beach Island natural turf
excessive rain what I wanna see more
because my mom we meet at the local bar
the sunny start to watch the rain start
off because I don't know how to business
plan if somebody puts in front of me
somebody else would never even consider
giving you money correct reverse
engineer the person cool I mean if this
is why you get conflicting opinions it's
why everybody gets conflicting opinions
because there's more than one way to do
it
but you need to know who you're doing it
with you come in here and make a
business plan and you actually know a
little bit about my spiel I'm out like
it's like if you didn't know me yeah
yeah because it's just how I bet you
know but like you go to a Goldman Sachs
kid who's like has public information
that she only believes in data and you
walk in and try to do the garyvee thing
your [ __ ] yeah I think it first it up
right - hey through myself of it like
what was my I believe in both in China
Taiwan well the answer is both always it
depends on is a 50/50 80/20 100 zero
right uh-huh yeah the other thing is
just do it yeah like it's a hell of a
lot better for you to go over seven
pitching your business then sitting in
your head on your couch and you make it
tastes bitter but the aftertaste is so
sweet with the stuff anytime you
wouldn't have seen this city who used to
calm down but now I got a speech that's
what that ball
[Music]
hopefull feels a lot better today though
for buying these versions up by use a
spinner like this good and then it goes
down economy gets [ __ ] terrible over
there's like so much [ __ ] you send to
science but if you love it that's the
other thing about music and technology
if you love it then that's a whole
different thing
then you so I can eat eat burger I'll be
straight I can't change burgers every
day I don't need I don't need anything
fancy I need to play my game that's what
I'm set surprise me that's why I'm the
best because I'm going to win because I
played for the game I don't need [ __ ]
I need [ __ ] and I don't hate on people I
want stuff everybody knows what they
want I want the game I think what's
money
really don't you know this you know they
spit on anybody you know you know like
you know you do know how I play I want
the [ __ ] that's exactly right
you know this is exactly vice I gave
this table yes face get into culture
outside of your own [ __ ] world
no he's a gamer like like you guys
should suck it you should go get [ __ ]
a country singer to sing a hook on some
of your [ __ ] that's some pretty blonde
girl that has 800,000 Instagram
followers and does country like I don't
know what kind of musician you I don't
want that's the one thing I always don't
is touch on the art that that's what
people do that I'm always giving them if
you're into it or if you're that kind of
artist you do it your [ __ ] will pop and
yeah man I remember the first time I got
offered a seat for real it's a good
story dude cause he goes why to give the
keynote at the internet marketing
conference how much can charge I was
about to say who I would love to say bet
okay like he you know you he was talking
slow he didn't get to say how much he
charged I was almost going to be like
sure I'll come to say my trip right he
goes how much in charge I'm like okay I
was like alright what's so much I'm a
businessman so I'm like okay I have no
idea what people get paid to speak but
I'm gonna throw the craziest [ __ ]
number ever because I could always come
down so I'm like $5,000 he goes ok great
he'll tell you the paperwork I'm Alan
[ __ ] he said yes fastest [ __ ] so I was
like [ __ ] and he's talking I'm blacked
out I'm happy and I'm like how do I get
I gotta get more and so yeah I don't
everything he said I go ok ok ok let me
meet at patron March 9 Florida directly
Florida $5,000 for a 30 minute talk no
no no I put an hour I said up
I said $10,000
he knows okay great how much lucky to
watch a lot of people Cesar knows why
you're bargaining basil just undo that
one while I go vision goes why are your
profits working
I got a broad right now I got a port for
my family
[Music]